going back to some of the college days
and being around your classmates what
was their mindset in terms of using that
degree as well what were their plans I
don't know I was kind of felt like i was
a bit on the outside looking in with
with those people my mindset was always
entrepreneurial and I thought well
where's the business in this or how do I
make this happen the idea of acting even
back then and still to this day always
seemed like one of these professions
where you weren't in any sort of control
there's always at the whim of somebody
saying you're good enough we pick you
and a lot a lot of times when I was like
a little chubby kid I was you know I was
like the last to be picked for anything
so I never really got I don't know if I
was lost to be picked for anything but
it seems like a good thing to say right
now I felt like you know with acting it
was always one of these things where
it's like you had to wait for somebody
to like you know look down this long
list of people and say okay we're going
to pick that guy and for me that always
seemed a little counterintuitive because
I thought well you know why couldn't I
just make my own thing and just act in
my own stuff if I wanted to you know why
why do I have to ask permission to be
successful and that was the first time
it dawned on me that maybe I could just
do something on my own and I didn't
really need you know somebody else to
say okay you're okay you can do this now
so once you got to LA when did that
proactive mindset take over and you
stopped being passive or maybe you were
never passive in coming to LA but when
did you start to put things in motion
whether it was a filmmaking stuff for
your project yeah so even making short
films after the New York thing and I met
with some friends and through the years
we make these short weekend backyard
Indies and there was this time right
before we made the feature where it was
a summer it was a hot day we were all
sitting around a living room and we had
this conversation going like okay well
summers coming let's make another short
movie this year and you can tell that
the enthusiasm for making another short
film just wasn't there it's like
defeated
we all felt defeated if we had to make
another short film you know it just it
would be a pointless use of our time
that's how we felt and somebody said you
know wait a second why couldn't we make
a feature and then the conversation kept
going yeah why couldn't we make a
feature and then somebody else said and
this is a quote i always use in my talks
and when I'm when I'm trying to
encourage people but you know the
question was asked that changed the
course of our filmmaking lives and that
question was given the resources that we
have right now what is the movie that we
can make this year and that of course
ended up being this really stupid zombie
movie that once we went to market with
it you know beyond our expectations and
went viral we had like the first week we
had like ten thousand people on our
website we crashed the servers and we
were like this this is something there's
something to this and you know I think
that's I'm going way beyond your
original question but I think when that
happened when we started getting all of
the response to the zombie movie our
phone was ringing with all these sales
agents and prospective distributors that
were saying hey you know give us your
movie and we'll get you into the shelves
at the local video store we were super
excited but but at that time I was just
starting and this was back in two
thousand six when we went to market I
was just starting to make the connection
between like targeted website traffic
and having a product to sell and we kept
waiting for one of these sales agents to
come along and give us a million-dollar
check because we were like a lot of
filmmakers and then going back to your
earlier question we were like we all
once again thought we were quits and
Tarantino we weren't and the movies
pretty low caliber and pretty low brow
but it ended up that all of the offers
that we got from sales agents and
distributors work deals because the deal
we felt would have been something that
would eventually pay his money if not up
front than some point and all of these
deals had these really crazy bullet
points that would have meant that had we
gone with any of those distributors we
would have never seen a dime
so we ended up just putting the movie on
amazon and I took some stuff off the
website using google analytics I looked
at all the pages where people were
exiting and not returning and I just
narrowed the website down into some real
basics one is we had a logo for the
movie we had some testimonials under the
logo we had a trailer and then we had a
Buy Now button we kept it very simple
and we were able to generate quite a lot
of revenue from doing just that frankly
because the movie gone viral we had a
lot of organic traffic so we didn't have
to pay for advertising and I now know
you know back then I was like oh this
should happen for every movie I now know
that's not the case for every movie but
it's set in the motion for me it gave me
going back to that whole you know
underlying philosophy that I have which
is you don't have to ask for permission
to be successful this was finally the
piece that unlocked that for me where I
realized that filmmaking for the right
movie with the right kind of strategy
could be a viable business it's not
always going to work out but all
businesses don't work out all the time
you know some do and some don't but it
taught me that I don't need a middleman
I don't need once again to ask somebody
that hey can I can you please can I
please distribute my movie can I please
take at the market that was a thing in
the past at that point and I really like
that
you